CBS News is investigating the Water
Crisis in Mississippi's capital city
which is home to 150 000 people
Jackson was left with no running water
for days after flooding in August caused
a water plant to fail our investigation
has been digging into one big decision
about a decade ago that was supposed to
help prevent this kind of situation
Jackson signed a 90 million dollar
contract with the international company
Siemens that promised Revenue to rebuild
the city's crumbling water system
instead the city is struggling just to
keep the water flowing our CBS News
Chief investigative correspondent Jim
Axelrod has the story Jim what'd you
find good morning I found that it's 2022
imagine this a state capital city in
America had no running water at all not
for an hour not for an overnight but for
nearly a week that's what Jackson
Mississippi faced last month leaving the
city's most vulnerable
desperate
our facility had absolutely no water we
were at zero water pressure Sydney
Howard manages the Hope Lodge in Jackson
where the American Cancer Society puts
up patients at no cost while they're
being treated I walked in here to see
that that gauge was at a zero it's what
do you do last month when the city's
water system failed Howard had to
scramble to evacuate 11 cancer patients
to facilities where the Taps and toilets
actually worked did you have 30 seconds
to think what is going on in Jackson
Mississippi where the Hope Lodge doesn't
have water yeah
but at the end of the day I'm here to
take care of lives and save lives
at the end of August floods drowned
Jackson's aging water treatment plant
crippling the system across the city
faucets ran with colors you never want
to see and the people of Jackson rushed
frantically to find whatever was fresh
enough to drink we do not have reliable
running water at scale it was exactly
the kind of Crisis the city hoped to
avert a decade earlier when it made a
deal with the Siemens Corporation it was
ridiculous to even support Decatur
stamps was elected to the Jackson City
Council the same year the city signed
the contract with Siemens which he
opposed what went wrong everything
everything went wrong Siemens came to
Jackson with a promise to upgrade the
city's water system the upgrades would
generate enough Revenue they said to
make Jackson's water system sustainable
for years to come all the commercial
meters are in stock with the city other
cities typically paid for projects like
this with a cut of the money saved on
the back end but Jackson agreed to pay
the full cost for those promises up
front the city took out a loan for 90
million dollars did Siemens keep those
promises no the biggest piece of the
plan replacing water meters across the
city was also the source of the biggest
problem thousands of the new meters
didn't work some meters measuring in
gallons when they were supposed to be
measuring in cubic feet meaning people
in Jackson were being charged as much as
seven and a half times what they should
have been throwing computer systems that
didn't operate as promised the bill was
more than 11
000 and people in this largely
African-American city with a per capita
income of twenty two thousand dollars
we're suddenly facing water bills they
had no hope of paying it's a done deal
now
and we the one got the better Coast the
city sued Siemens and some
subcontractors alleging in part a
massive fraud orchestrated by Siemens
that caused more than 450 million
dollars in losses to Jackson promise
made
promise kept the mayor claimed Victory
when Siemens and the subcontractors
settled even though they did not admit
wrongdoing Siemens essentially paid back
the 90 million dollars the company sent
us a short statement saying the
agreement settled the issue and the
project did not end as either party
hoped is it fair to assume that made the
city whole oh no even that was a sad job
after the law firm took a 30 million
dollar cut and tens of millions more
went to pay back loans needed to keep
the water running the city did not have
nearly enough to fund the much needed
repairs according to this city audit
Jackson will be paying back Millions on
the Siemens deal at six percent interest
until the year 2040. sad sometimes I
Gotta Laugh to Keep Them crying there
are just lots of problems in the city of
Jackson Michael Regan runs the U.S
Environmental Protection Agency in
Washington as it relates to Siemens and
the water meters and the building we
understand that that's a part of the
problem Regan has traveled twice to
Jackson in the last month as he focuses
on cities where he says chronic under
investment has led to infrastructure
problems how many other Jacksons
exist in our country right now dozens if
not more when you look at the data black
and brown communities and low-income
communities have been disproportionately
impacted by environmental hazard and
harm because of a lack of investment
so Jackson's water is back up and
running again for now but as for
Solutions now it's up to the city the
state of Mississippi and even the
federal government to find a way forward
but some estimates put the total price
tag for fixing Jackson's water system at
one billion dollars wow this is so wrong
on so many levels and when you ask the
question how many other Jacksons never
happens in places like Greenwich or
Beverly Hills never happens in those
kind of places but we are going to find
and Shine the Light on other places
where it does happen and continuing to
press for answers and even Seaman's
answer is that enough under these
circumstances we don't admit any
wrongdoing and the project we do admit
the project didn't work out as either
party okay yeah no doubt about it Jim
thank you so much